i'm fascinated by the concept of control
and and um throughout this pandemic and
and even the social unrest from from uh
uh from some of the social stuff that's
happening in our country um uh it's been
fascinating to understand how people
feel and how control relates as to how
they um respond when we feel out of
control it actually increases our stress
dramatically there's been lots of
studies on this um
there was a a great study that was done
i think in the 70s
called the white hole studies where back
in the 70s there was a group of social
scientists who wanted to study the
phenomenon that they labeled and called
executive stress syndrome right the the
belief that if you make your way up the
ranks you feel more stress right okay as
they wanted to study executive stress
and they they did it in whitehall which
is the the halls of government in the uk
because they could account for
standardized
health care it would be variances in
health care what they discovered was
there was no such thing as executive
stress syndrome it was completely made
up
and what they discovered is is as you
make your way up the ranks of an
organization your stress levels actually
go down and the people who suffer the
highest stress levels are actually
people some of the lowest levels and the
reason had nothing to do with
responsibility it had nothing to do with
number of hours worked it had to do with
feeling in control
that when somebody's senior more senior
in their career they have a little more
control as to the direction of their day
the direction of their career when
you're at the lowest level somebody's
always telling you what to do and
somebody's always correcting your
behavior so it's always catching you and
you do something wrong and they find the
highest rates of diabetes and some
cancers and heart disease actually at
the people who felt the less the least
in control and so giving people control
giving people agency letting people know
that they have say in the course of
their career or if they screw something
up to give them an opportunity to try
and mend it or catching people doing
things right which is something we we
could all do better at you know we catch
people doing things wrong you know you
only send an email when something went
wrong but you never sent an email and
that's everything went right it's all
about giving people a sense of control
and letting them work together and
figure things out um and it and it has a
dramatic impact on how people feel about
themselves and more important how they
relate to each other i recently learned
that the buttons for crosswalks
completely fake they don't they're just
there to give you
a perception of control same with a
button in an elevator shut the doors
well that one i know in europe they work
you hit the button and they close but i
think it's funny how much we
we like have you ever had it where you
hit the button
and the light doesn't go on
and this like panic or or you show up
somebody's already standing at the
elevator that clearly the light's
already the the button's already pressed
the light is on but you go over and you
press the button i mean it is funny how
we like to sort of exert our control
wherever possible even when rationally
we don't need to
when we trust people we want to give
them agency and empower them i think the
challenge is um is is is what goes first
you know um and i think for anybody in a
leadership position i think one of the
things that they they
they fail to appreciate
is that trusting
is one of the risks a leader has to take
and i've never heard a great leader say
prove to me why i should trust you
rather leaders show up and trust and i i
hear it i get pushed back all the time
well i didn't get to choose my team i
you kind of asked me to trust them at
the gate well you begin to choose your
children
you love them out the gate leaders take
the risk to trust and it's actually the
opposite it's the team that says will
prove to us why we should trust you
and that the leader has to demonstrate
trustworthiness that the team would
trust them but actually leaders have to
take the risk to trust their teams and
the more they give trust
the more they get trust the more they
give trust the more their
practicing empowerment i'm going to let
you do that as one great leader
that i adore her name is uh general lori
robinson
she says to her teams there's nothing
you can't break there's nothing you can
break that i can't help fix
i i just love that notion that i mean
i'm here to help you even if you get it
wrong